It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa!
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU!
And today we're your host of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Thank you all Ruffians for joining us today for our 143rd episode!
143!
BAU BAU!
BAU!
It's gonna be episode 150 before we know it, Ruffians!
Are you ready?
150!
Another milestone!
BAU BAU!
For Ruffians joining us for the very first time today, FUWAMOCO Morning is a short-format morning show held every Friday, Wednesday, and Monday.
A.K.A.
FUWAMOCO!
And it's hosted by us, FUWAMOCO!
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face and help you
Start your day off on the right paw.
Please tweet your thoughts with the hashtag!
Hashtag FWMCMorning!
Let's go BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
It's FUWAMOCO Morning!
That's the solid answer.
It's morning!
Yes!
Morning!
Good job!
Yeah!
BAU BAU!
That means we're gonna have a bunch of fun doing this, of course.
We can!
But!
Before that, Moco-chan, we have some very exciting things to share with the Ruffians, right?
First!
Huh?
There's that one, right?
You need the news!
To be informed!
Information!
Sometimes information's scary, no?
There's been another... Pero Sighting.
Pero Sighting.
Well, maybe this is important information.
Okay, listen up Ruffians!
Listen up!
Okay, we're gonna take a look.
Okay, where was Pero Sighted this time?
De-den!
Oh!
That's a collection!
A collection with a nasty problem in it!
That is an important site.
Yeah.
Right in the middle.
Pero, stop taking up some very important space there.
You can throw him out!
Get rid of him!
Throw him in the garbage!
Ruffians, you know what we're gonna say, right?
There's some more super cute FUWAMOCO merch still to come!
So you need to make sure you know that Pero isn't taking up any unnecessary room in there with her treasures!
Those are her treasures!
That's not where it is.
Pretty nasty.
It's a place for treasures.
It's a place for
It's a hat, Moco-chan!
I got confused, I had to take a look at what was in the photo!
That would be a different collection.
Not a collection?
No, this is the best collection.
A nice collection!
But you know, it's time to toss him out.
Maybe you can lure him out of there with some poisoning.
Well, good luck!
I hope he doesn't turn on you.
Be careful.
BAU BAU!
Misunderstanding!
Huh?
No misunderstanding!
It's been cleared out!
It's done.
BAU BAU!
No misunderstandings!
But you're my sister, Moco-chan.
Why?
Have a howl of a day!
Nice!
Ruffians!
This is so very exciting news!
It's official!
You can now find FUWAMOCO whenever you go to FamilyMart in Japan!
Live right now with me!
Whenever you get two of the special gummies, then you can get a very special clear folder with FUWAMOCO on it!
With Airi-senpai, Kaori-senpai, Bayi-senpai, and taking away hololive!
FUWAMOCO!
But it's very specific.
Paper gummies, okay?
Yeah, okay.
These are the really good gummies, okay?
Yeah, because you know, you can get like gummy bears and be like, oh nice.
One, two.
Two bites and the gummy bear is gone.
It's gone, right?
You pulverized it with your teeth.
These are special gummies, okay?
They're like, I know you have a chin.
And you're gonna be using it.
You're gonna use the jaw.
Yes, all the teeth.
Yep, yep.
You know it.
Moco-chan, it's like you made the gummies you dreamt of!
I like really hard gummies.
Yes!
But the flavors, okay?
Now pay attention because I want to ask Ruffians, what flavors?
What flavor do you think FUWAMOCO?
We're in charge of hard.
FUWAMOCO's flavors.
I want to see.
I want to see Ruffians!
Damede kowa!
BAU BAU!
That's correct!
Moco kowai!
But, but the next question.
Taro, Aira-senpai, Calli-senpai, Bay-senpai, what flavors are they in charge of?
Huh?
That's the next question, huh?
Strawberry is bae!
Strawberry is bae
Tofu flavor gummy!
Energy drink flavor!
Hard cola.
Right there, Moco-chan.
Soft, normal cola.
Fuzzy cola.
Right, Moco-chan?
So you're gonna have to try Cali-senpai's hard cola.
And compare it to Moco-chan's fuzzy cola, right?
What's the difference?
You have to find out!
Did we try both of them?
Wow, with FUWAMOCO we went to go get our paws on them right away!
Most of the gummies were sold out.
So we haven't been able to compare the core flavors of Ruffians with the adult bouquets.
And you know what?
You have to buy two gummies to get one clear folder.
So that means...
Gotta get 4 gummies.
You're gonna be known as the Ruffian that has all the gummies.
Hand them out to your friends, okay?
You can't eat them all yourself.
If you do, then maybe you might be trading in your jaw.
You won't be chewing much else?
No.
Just gummies.
Yeah.
That's four days of gummies, okay?
You're eating them right now!
I hope you enjoy them!
I can't wait to start the morning.
Right.
Gummies and breakfast.
Well, you'll have to go and check out.
Get your paws on your holo-ear and clear folders at FUWAMIMO.
Oh!
FUWAMIMO's throughout Japan.
Every single one.
That's a lot of FUWAMIMO's.
FUWAMOCO.
There might be some more surprises coming up soon.
So keep your eyes on it, okay Ruffians?
BAU BAU!
We also have what the clear files look like.
Very helpful, very handy.
I like the size too.
I feel like the size isn't the standard full paper size.
You know it makes it perfect for all those things you know.
If you want to put it in your bag but you don't have that much space.
A nice medium size.
Yeah.
Wait they're so cute!
Thank you!
BAU BAU!
The paw press is cute.
Right!
I like it.
I like my press right now too.
It's good to like it.
BAU BAU!
There's also some other very exciting and very strong things happening!
April Fool's Surprise Advent!
Well, we kind of surprised you with super silly event!
Yeah, special April Fool's Advent!
We might have got into some trouble with, you know, crazy energy drink.
Energy drink?
What kind of drink was it?
Fire, fire.
Thank you Ruffians for joining Shiori and Nerissa and Biboo.
Unfortunately we couldn't participate this time.
We are, you know, FUWAMOCO.
We are really excited to be a part of this.
Especially, you know, it's a very special night.
Yeah, it's okay though.
If you make a mistake, it's okay.
But you know, this is extremely FUWAMOCO!
Yes, we're so excited!
We've been really looking forward to it for months, you know!
We're so cute!
We're really looking forward to get excited, you know, to see everything!
To see the Ruffians' reactions!
So you know, we're really sorry that
It didn't quite work out, but... But we wanted to say a big big thank you to Lulucano and all the creators for making an amazing, jaw-dropping, awesome video for a cover of I Don't Even Want to Say It.
You are so good!
You know, and all the creators, all the stars.
Thank you so much!
We love you so much!
It's amazing!
Yeah, and the V.I.Chat world, and Super BAU FUWAMOCO!
Thank you!
You know, as we got updates on the project, sometimes it would be really late at night.
And you know, at 1.30,
I think it was about 3 or 4 AM.
And we were just cackling away!
You didn't go down too far!
Are you kidding me?!
I'm glad I laughed a lot!
BAU BAU BAU!
Were you hitting the desk, Ruffians?
You too?
Yeah.
I feel like I need to, you know, FUWAMOCO Morning pause and go watch the video right now again.
Again and again and again.
So, Ruffians!
Did you see that?
You need to go watch it again, okay?
With FUWAMOCO, we did our best, you know.
Singing as strong as we could with every ounce of FUFUFUZ that we had.
It's a little...
You are not a chihuahua, I'm a Ruffian.
So we've sung Aya Torimodose before, okay?
It's a fun song!
We've sung it for Rock n' Rawr Party, right?
Right?
Have we?
Tough boy we've sung.
We are living.
Living into ages.
We've sung Aya Torimodose before.
Not sure.
Maybe.
I don't know.
Just tough boy.
Okay, but Aya Torimodose was gonna happen.
This time.
We sung it different.
Yeah, we were like, okay, I'm gonna sing it like this.
And then... It didn't end up that way.
Yeah.
So it's a little bit more... Beastly standing.
Demon dog.
Yeah.
Maybe not the most flattering.
Entire soul.
It felt like more muscle than entire soul.
Yeah, all the muscles are flexed.
I hope that you listen to it lots.
Listen to all of the Advent.
Put everything into this color.
And thank you again, Ruffians, for having a lot of fun today.
We're both together, and you know I'm the best at the fun.
But if you haven't had enough fun yet,
De-den!
Well Ruffians, now you can dive right in because the VR chat world has been released!
So gather some Ruffians, Monopolis, Pebbles, Geobullets, and we hope you have a lot of fun together in the VR chat world, okay?
Go Ruffians, go!
BAU BAU!
Please check it out again!
Yeah, you can have a battle royale together.
You know it!
There's lots of fun!
More stuff to check out!
Yeah.
BAU BAU!
Thank you, Ruffians!
And please check out the cover again, okay?
BAU BAU!
And!
Blazing Sun!
It's Karin-senpai's birthday!
Karin-senpai's happy birthday!
BAU BAU BAU BAU!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
Have a howl of a day!
9pm PT!
There's going to be a brand new song being released!
And the MV is animated by Calli-senpai herself!
That's crazy!
And it seems like she maybe just finished it too, looking at her tweets!
I'm super looking forward to it so let's please go cheer her on!
I'm so excited!
And Biboo and Shiori are guests too!
But we wanted to say a big big happy birthday to Karin-senpai!
You know, we're really really thankful to have such a special senpai that we can always count on.
Listen to us and brighten up our world tonight.
We're excited to watch you play!
Thank you!
Tell me to have a howl of a day!
Bye bye!
Ruffians!
You may be seeing some...
Interesting things floating around Twitter.
Adventures!
FUWAMOCO!
Looks like we might be going on some adventures!
Because there's a fun FUWAMOCO adventure being in production.
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
But, you know, it really reminds us of the games that we used to play together with Bubble Puppy!
I wanna play together with Bubble Puppy!
Not with me.
Not with Moco-chan.
Me too.
FUWAMOCO!
But right now it seems like there's some pretty regular daily updates.
And it's really interesting to see what's going on.
So let's continue to cheer them on, not cheer them off again.
Well, making a game isn't easy.
But the number one thing is that one, right?
No pressure, no pressure ever.
If it's done, it gets done.
If it doesn't get done, it doesn't get done.
That's okay.
Just have fun.
BAU BAU!
Do your best!
Much pressure.
No pressure, Ruffians!
I just want to cheer on.
I want to cheer all of you on, okay?
Just like you know, recently we were looking at
You know all the special letters that you've wrote us, Ruffians?
And you know the special treasures that we've gotten from the comic market.
That's right.
We want to cheer on all the special things, your dreams, and everything to protect your smiles too, Ruffians!
Yeah.
Okay.
BAU BAU!
You wrote song letters!
Song letters?
We have a very special letter.
Also in our hearts.
BAU BAU!
Ruffians!
FUWAMOCO, we've had some special milestones recently!
Wow, our newest song cover, Crescent Moon, has released!
FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
Thank you, my favorite BAU BAU!
Thank you!
Also, just coincidentally, our song cover of White Love that we released back in 2023 has reached 1.5 million views!
BAU BAU!
What year is it?
2025, Moco-chan!
Are you sure that's right?
Yeah.
Was it?
2024?
No.
No?
2023?
Yeah.
Okay, Ruffians.
It was 2023!
Yeah!
Thank you, Ruffians!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
Lots and lots of love.
It's a cover of a legendary idol group's beat song.
And it's a very emotional one too.
It's a little bit different from present morning, you know?
It's a bit more of an upbeat, somewhat of a nostalgic feel too.
So... Please check it out if you haven't, okay?
FUWAMOCO Thank you, FUWAMOCO!
Look at you, you need to do it.
I'll show you some more song covers.
Do more singing.
Look forward to it.
Thank you, FUWAMOCO!
Hi!
Wow, Moco-chan.
It's been a week.
Ruffians!
How has it been for you?
Because FUWAMOCO has been a week.
It's been a bit rough.
We've been a bit rough.
Painful.
It's been difficult.
Oh, what was it please?
You've been sick.
You missed us.
Moco-chan, do you have anything to make me feel better?
I can't promise anything, okay?
But... I'll do my best!
BAU BAU!
Ruffians!
It's that time again!
It's not that time of week, but it is now!
Because I say it is!
It's time for a FUWAMOCO Code Pup Talk!
And you're gonna hear it from me!
That's straight from me!
FUWAMOCO!
Ruffians!
I know.
Sometimes things just don't go how you planned it.
No matter how much you prepare.
No matter how excited you are.
Everything.
Sometimes things just get in your way and it doesn't work out.
I can feel like it's hard to overcome it.
But you can do it!
You're strong!
Okay!
So, let's do our best to try to expect the unexpected situations that come our way.
But, ultimately, the most important thing with times like that is how we deal with it.
You know?
So, sometimes, you can only do your best, and it's not anyone's fault.
It's just too bad.
So, let's keep on moving ahead, okay?
And remember, be kind to yourself!
I believe in ya!
Ganbatte de!
BAU BAU!
Thank you Moco-chan!
I believe in you too Moco-chan!
I believe in you Moco-chan!
Do you hear me?
Do
There's a cute Doggie of the Day waiting for us.
Maybe.
Let's take a look at the Doggie of the Day.
Today's Doggie of the Day is... De-den!
A doggy with no name.
Doesn't have a name, Moco-chan.
What's your doggy's name?
What's your doggy's name, huh?
BAU BAU!
We're gonna have to give him a name, huh?
Guess so.
What's the name?
Okay.
3, 2, 1.
The Doggie of the Day is Mr. I don't know if it's a Mr. Mr. Lawyer!
Mr. Lawyer!
Cheddar!
Mr. Lawyer Cheddar.
Mr. Cheddar the lawyer.
Mr. Cheddar the lawyer is his full name.
Yes.
Nickname is Cheese.
It's not exact FUWAMOCO-chan!
Yes.
Mr. Cheddar the lawyer nicknamed Cheese.
That's the Doggie of the Day!
Well, Mr. Cheddar... I'm sorry, I will correct myself.
Mr. Chatter the Lawyer?
That was it!
Mr. Chatter the Lawyer.
Nickname Cheese.
Wasabi.
But it's okay, you know, because just the presence of Hoshifuwamoco.
His name is Duke.
Duke.
Mr. Chatter the Lawyer.
Nickname Cheese.
Also known as Duke.
Yes!
I know!
Everything's changed because FUWAMOCO!
We're down, we're plushy, we're fluffy, and we're fuzzy!
That's the most important thing.
Yes!
I know, but...
Moco-chan!
How does Mr. China the lawyer nickname cheese also known as Duke BAU BAU?
BAU BAU!
I can feel the hope radiating from him.
Mr. Chatter the Lawyer nicknamed Cheese also known as Duke is a very good boy.
He likes to enjoy his Ruffian's favorite thing together with her.
He loves this Ruffian.
And you know,
That's a feeling that we all share.
Remember, Ruffians!
Remember, your FUWAMOCO plushies keep us close to you.
Especially, you know, when you're feeling a bit cloudy.
Or cold.
Yeah.
BAU BAU!
Thank you!
Thank you, Mr. Cheddar the Lawyer aka Cheese.
Also known as Duke.
Yes.
BAU BAU!
Well, it's spring now, Ruffians.
You cannot stay indoors.
You cannot be like, it's cold.
It's spring now.
It might be cold, but it's spring, so you have to go inside.
So let's take a look on where you've been on a walk.
Today, I went on a walk.
We have... De-den!
This is a cool forest.
The trees look so cool.
Oh!
You're out exploring different places in Japan.
Fukuoka!
That's quite a bit further.
Wow.
You know my super idol.
Really unique for how the trees are so thin.
Tree, tree, tree, tree, tree.
But they all want their own space.
But they're not gonna have too many leaves.
I like the ground.
They do.
Wow.
Being watched can help with feeling.
Tree is curvy.
Why are you looking at the tree like that, huh?
There's something that's more than a tree there, Moco-chan.
Are you using your imagination?
Just trees.
BAU BAU!
Don't mind anything weird, okay, Ruffians?
And next we have our Question of the Day!
Today's Question of the Day is... De-den!
Now that your voyager has even more options available before going live, how exactly do each of you decide what you want to wear?
Like, is today's stream more of a glasses occasion?
Or this game looks chilly so it'd be a good idea to bundle up?
I love this!
This!
We don't know anything!
We don't know!
You know, we've been wearing our out-of-the-boat outfits a lot recently.
But, we're kind of in a bit of a... When do we go back?
Yeah.
You know, it's not just a, wait, how am I going to do my hair today?
Do I want glasses or not?
It's a, when, when, when should I wear what?
I, you know, I, my usual clothes are pretty comfy too.
When an occasion calls for it, when you feel like it.
You know, it's time for our New Year's Office!
Once it's not New Year's anymore, maybe it's not really a celebratory time, then, you know, it's time to put it away.
But, now we're not really sure what to do here.
And I feel like even for the New Year's Office, isn't that a shame?
It's a shame, they're so pretty!
So then when?
Yeah.
I don't know, Ruffians.
I think we do kinda think maybe what humor or maybe what fits what we're about to do and try to match that.
But... We're not sure if we're making the right decisions.
Yeah, maybe Ruffians you could let us know like you want to see more of and your thoughts too.
Yeah!
Any choice is good.
Maybe there's a Donkey Kong kind of outfit.
What?
Donkey Kong?
Donkey Kong kind of outfit?
What's a Donkey Kong kind of outfit to you Ruffians?
Twin tails more Donkey Kong.
Grab onto the twin tails.
What?
New Year's for Donkey Kong!
Oh!
Glad to see what it is done, Ruffians!
Maybe you'll be surprised.
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much, Ruffians, for all your submissions to FUWAMOCO Morning!
Ruffians, remember!
You are a very important part of FUWAMOCO Morning!
So we're always looking for more of your submissions with the hashtag #FWMCMORNING.
It's all the other days, your vlogs, it's springtime,
Don't forget!
Reporting questions!
We're getting lots of great questions recently, but send us more questions, Ruffians!
And Pero Sightings too, you know!
Don't forget.
Thank you, Ruffians!
Thank you!
BAU BAU!
Don't forget to use the hashtag.
Okay.
Hashtag important.
Hashtag FWMCMORNING.
BAU BAU!
And for our next stream!
Wow!
We kind of just talked about it, but!
De-den!
And 6pm PT!
We're going to be continuing our adventure in Donkey Kong Country 2!
Yes!
Business!
Moco-chan, how is it going?
It has been running this entire time we've been playing Donkey Kong Country 2, which is kind of amazing because I felt like we just played it last month.
Yep, last month was apparently October.
But this nest has still been on!
It is still doing great!
The controller fell on the ground.
So we will share what it has been on the whole time.
Yeah, we kinda surprised the class.
Why is it like this?
Why is it here?
Yeah.
So we'll share it in memory of you four kids!
Doggy Pack!
BAU BAU!
But, please join us, Ruffians!
We're gonna be going bananas just like usual.
BAU BAU!
And we'll take a peek at our schedule!
Well, we have also
We're gonna be revisiting a little bit.
How's that going Moco-chan?
We had some issues with our data.
Not going yet.
I'm sure Moco-chan will be able to get right back where we were very soon.
And you'll be a pro, right?
And on Sunday, very early in the morning at 4am PT, we're gonna be having an off-collab!
On ???'s channel!
A ??? off-collab!
What could that be?
Who are we collabing with?
Who aren't we collabing with?
Who could it be?
Very secretive.
You have to find out who it is!
It's up to the senpai.
We don't call the shots.
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
But YouTube will be correct.
When we put up the waiting room for it, it will be at the correct time, okay?
I know it's a couple times, but whatever.
It's not a mistake.
BAU BAU!
Thank you, Ruffians!
Thank you so much for joining us today for FUWAMOCO Morning!
I'm forgetting something important!
Ruffians!
Michael Ruffians joining us in the archive today.
Your FUWAMOCO word is... BAU BAU!
Oh my gosh!
BAU BAU!
Fuwamoco don't play Mohan!
Not yet.
Huh?
We haven't played Mohan yet.
There's a lot of games we haven't played that we really wanna play.
Yeah, now the Switch 2 is coming out, right?
That's okay, I'll just play games on my snacks.
How many game consoles have been out?
There's so many games for all the consoles!
We're going at a deep and dark pace, okay Ruffians?
Yes.
Enjoy FUWAMOCO!
I had a dream about playing that.
FUWAMOCO Morning!
Thank you Ruffians for joining us today!
Ruffians, we say BAU BAU for now.
We'd like to shout out to some of our Extra Special Ruffians today!
Siawawon!
BAU BAU!
Spawth!
Chuuudon!
BAU BAU!
Rumpapanda!
Birika!
BAU BAU!
Night owl!
Attacker!
BAU BAU!
Juice not sauce!
Hunger!
BAU BAU!
Ayakashi guy!
Boy!
BAU BAU!
We hope you have a howl of a day!
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!